starting at the top with the chrome logo
it's pretty clear that it's a set of
colors set of lines set of gradients and
some pretty regular shapes in fact if
you open it up in dev tools you'll see
that this is an SVG making it a vector
image Sams cute kittens are a photo
which means that is by default a raster
image that is to say it's a grid of
colored dots the Mexican flag is pretty
complex but believe it or not this is an
SVG making it a vector graphic this
middle part here is obviously the tough
part while it does look complex you can
make it with an SVG if you don't believe
me check out in dev tools this files
source and for this last gradient it can
be defined as some geometric rules
governing how the color should change so
this one is also a vector image so the
final tally is that the chrome logo is a
vector the kitten is a raster and then
the Mexican flag repeat background and
gradient backgrounds are all vector
images